well it seems like a lot of the stress
like you just said came from uncertainty
it came from did you go home at night
sometimes and going I just I don't know
if it's I'm giving them what they want I
don't know if this is the guy I don't
know what I'm did you carry a lot of the
stress a lot of the the weight on you no
pun intended man I always felt like at
the end of the day because I I worked so
hard people have no idea dude I I set up
entirely new methods for how I can learn
scenes so that I could learn everybody's
line including mine so I would learn not
just my lines I would learn everybody
else's and by knowing the scene that
well it gave me the opportunity to have
20 people tell me how they want me to do
the scene and to Pivot and do it that
way so I left so many options on the
table season one there was no question
about like did I get the right Reacher I
knew there was some version of Reacher
there you just had take your pick you
know and that that came from that that
came from the work so it wasn't you know
it wasn't so much that it was just
um uh
just uh just the sheer the the workload
that it took to uh to to be able to
honor that that necessity you know was
um it was it was a lot it was a lot um
and uh that part of the process is is
gone now you know so now I can approach
it much more like any other project or
film you know and that's um it just
helps you know yeah what about what
about the family like your family you've
got you live in Florida uh no I just
stld my place in Florida yeah all right
so you're
gone yeah gone from Florida I mean look
here's the thing I um since Reacher came
out there was there was this moment you
know I I I I I fought really hard for
Reacher it took months and months and
months to convince everybody that I was
the
guy it you know I was passed on the
first time I think I mentioned to you
maybe last I was passed on in the very
beginning beginning of the process um
like everybody was and I think that was
because I'm 63 Reacher 65 I think they
they were trying to you know everybody's
trying to get a super authentic version
of Reacher on screen and um so there's
always kind of an asps in my mind you
know um when it comes to this role uh
but I had to really fight for that
and
um the now now that we're in it
um it's explod like the career's
exploded because of uh what happened
after reard a beforehand we were waiting
the whole town was like let's see what
happens when it airs there was months of
Silence nobody was picking up the phone
there was no conversations about scripts
um it it aired and within 48 hours I had
20 offers on my desk from the biggest
producers and studios in town and it
hasn't slowed up I mean it's still like
every day we're getting phone calls from
some of the the most legendary people
you can imagine give me do give me one
so I did a movie okay so I did a movie
with Jerry Jerry B Brooker produced guy
Richie directed called Ministry of UN
gentlemanly Warfare this is a movie I
did for Lionsgate domestic and Amazon
international um so some partners that I
knew and have relationships with on this
and some some new relationships formed
um this movie is so good you can't I
cannot believe this movie is so fun
there's nothing like it it's like guy
Richie at his best based on a true story
there World War II uh Heroes who um were
essentially the first uh special ops um
it's a it's a told in guy Richie style
wow um it's super
cool um I just went into that feeling
very lucky to be a part of this cast you
know Henry caval and Alex peder and you
know Henry just a great amazing cast
um Jared bromer calls because he saw the
movie Just A A few days ago he saw he
saw a cut of the film and um you know he
said we have to do um we have to do
something together like with you out
front come on I know Jerry a long time
I'm buddies with him name drop but like
you like Jerry for Jerry to call someone
to call an you know how like like like
like a high adventure like nobody does
high adventure better than this guy no
and and uh and it's it's the toughest
genre to make I think and um you know
for him to call U you know one of the
most legendary producers of all time you
know you get those kind of calls it's
like there's just no better feeling you
know um and and it's it's because of
Reacher that those kind of calls are
coming in I wouldn't have done that job
if I my career had been fueled by
Reacher and Jerry is like the kind of
guy he's so softspoken he's so
intimidating but such a sweet guy but
he's just like and you when you meet him
I remember the first time cuz I I you
know I had this I was in this Hockey
League I'm still in the hockey league
and it was Jerry bookheimer hockey
league on Sunday nights and I've done it
for 25 years and and it's producers and
actors and like you know Keith for
southernland and a bunch of you know and
then Pro players would play and it was
competitive and fun you know the first
time I go Jerry hey thanks for having me
he was like you he just nodded and then
few months later like hey Jerry's like
how are you and then a year later two
years 3 years was like hey
Michael he knows my name four years hey
Michael uh you know conversations and
slowly I built this little friendship
with Jerry and you know we' go and he go
uh you know if you'd like to fly with us
in my private jet to Vegas uh like yeah